hey guys it's dr. Burke here in this
video I'm going to show you the five
weight loss mistakes that everyone makes
number one thinking it's not working
when it really is working many times the
person is being successful burning fat
but not weight loss because the muscle
is increasing which is heavier as you're
losing fat so really the goal is to burn
more fat increase body fat percentage or
some of the testing that I do is more
sophisticated I can look deep into the
body to see if you're burning fat and if
the person is not is not losing weight
they're kind of frustrated but really it
is working so the last thing you want to
do is give up or change something when
it's really working so here's what you
do measure this focus on the size to
close how the closest fitting forget the
scale okay that's number one number two
using the calorie model so they do this
a lot in Weight Watchers where all
calories are equal you know doesn't
matter
what kind of calories they are as long
as you keep them lower that is not true
because certain calories affect the
weight differently for example let's say
you have calories from protein like
chicken or fish right and you have
calories from fruit fruit will block fat
burning especially if your metabolism is
lower sugar will do the same so it's the
hidden sugars so you really want to look
at the type of food not necessarily the
calorie so that's a huge mistake
especially with hidden sugars like fruit
yogurt and you know about the grains and
the pastas and the cereal and all that
starches but I think the big one is is
the fruit people don't realize that will
stop fat burning especially apples
number three eating too many nuts
so here the person is they go on the
eating plan and what do they snack on
tons and tons and tons of nuts and the
problem with nuts is it's very hard to
eat just a little bit at night you even
pistachios next thing you know you're
eating the whole bag so when you eat too
many nuts what it does is it interferes
with the gallbladder the live
and that creates bloating and that
creates right shoulder pain so many
people have that problem there's eating
too many nuts now the problem with nuts
is that yes they might be low in
calories whatever and they have some
protein but there is about a bit of fat
in there and I'm not against fat but you
can overdo it there's a thing called
ketosis which is fat burning and you can
measure it through the urine if you're
in ketosis that means you're burning fat
and the ketosis diet is all about eating
more fat the problem is if you're older
and your metabolism is low you may be
burning fat but the fat that you're
burning is those nuts and not your own
fat so yes you can overdo it with too
many nuts and too much fat number four
everything in moderation don't you hear
that all the time you know it's okay as
long as everything's moderation just a
little bit it won't get you well here's
the thing the purpose of fat is to
protect you against the starvation of
sugar fat is there as a backup fuel in
case you run out of sugar that means
that most people don't burn in the fat
because they never starve themselves of
sugar they go on a low-carb diet which
might not be enough starvation of sugar
when you read labels always look at the
sugar grams okay those must be zero you
literally if your metabolism is slow you
can't do moderation of sugars you have
to do zero sugars to even be get into
fat burning why because just a little
bit of the wrong thing juice or candy or
sugar can literally bump you at a fat
burning for 24 to 48 you leave sometimes
72 hours so let's say you drink glass
wine on Monday and then Wednesday and
then Saturday
well good luck you just blew the whole
weight you're not going to lose anyway
because that a little bit of the wrong
thing can bump you out of fat-burning so
this whole theory about everything in
moderation is not workable if your
metabolism is slow now the other thing
is that we don't there's certain things
we don't want to go in moderation we
want to go very very
very high and that would be vegetables
and I know you probably need to increase
that so an average body needs between 7
to 10 cups of salad or vegetable every
single day why because that will provide
for the at least the minimum amount of
nutrients especially potassium magnesium
and a lot of the other electrolytes you
need those foods to get that nutrition
and if you're doing a little side salad
1 cup it's just not enough to get the
nutrition and then you create all sorts
of other problems and I'm not going to
get into all the benefits of that but
you don't want to go moderate with your
vegetables you want to go a lot unless
you're bloating okay but you want to go
very high with those moderate protein
and no sugar okay so that's number four
lastly we have number five focusing only
on the weight this is a big one so the
truth is you don't really have a weight
problem you have a weight symptom the
weight is the tip of the iceberg what's
deeper is a lot of health issues like
sleep problems let's say you're not
sleeping if you're not sleeping you're
not going to lose weight so you want to
fix the sleeping let's say you have
digestive problems constipated so you're
bloating well that's what you need to
fix because if you're eating a lot of
vegetables and you're just bloated that
could be the reason why you're not
losing weight so I look for instead of
the way they look for sleeping digestion
inflammation your menstrual cycle hot
flashes that would be hormones I look
for your energy level your mood your
stress tolerance those are the factors
that go beyond weight that will really
make you successful with weight loss if
you focus on them versus just the weight
and calories okay so I hope you learned
something from this but these are the
most common mistakes with weight loss
that everyone makes I'll see in the next
video